you need to get out of the paint within
two three seconds and again just a
one-shot technical gains from a left
shell ball rattles that one in
vanes on James five on the 24 James
drives gets in the paint falling away is
up and good we see this first to wear
till mrs. Thompson try to keep it alive
gets the offensive rebound James from
well beyond the arc rattles it in LeBron
James 3 for 4 from the field he's got 7
points comes away might be some witness
on the court players are slipping James
drives layup County and one got hit in
the head and a chance to give the Cavs
their first lead of the night trying to
stop LeBron James shot clock at 7 here a
couple of heavyweights going out of art
James just open pores though just too
big no it's being content to be playing
behind and that led to the double and
the easy cut James for three that's
LeBron James from downtown I like to see
him put Aron Baynes in the pick-and-roll
and that's exactly what the gue trying
number three and nails it his third
three-pointer and the Cavs back up fight
they are Smith and Clarkson out there
right now with a James drives on Horford
gets inside and lays it in off the glass
now Cole goes in that corner waddle ball
deflected picked up by James turn shoots
and hits he's got 27 and a lead back up
the three for Cleveland 6 on the 24
games between the legs drives continues
off-balance backs at home
he is loved that angle shot throughout
these playoffs hit some big ones